we still are battling at least in the
United States but conceit that humans
are separate from the rest of nature
that an unbridgeable gap separates
humans from the other plants and animals
that we are the particular beneficiaries
of the concern of the creator of the
universe more than any of the 10 million
other species of plants and animals on
the earth when in fact all of our
vaunted uniqueness turns out to be
shared here we are like mites on a plum
and the plum is this little planet and
it goes around an insignificant local
star the Sun and that star is on the on
the obscure outskirts of an ordinary
galaxy the Milky Way which contains 400
billion other stars and this galaxy is
just one of something like a hundred
billion other galaxies that make up the
universe and it is now beginning to look
this universe is one of an enormous
number maybe even an infinite number of
other closed-off universes so the idea
that we are central
that we are the reason there is a
universe is pathetic
we have to simply come to grips with the
real universe that we really live in and
if some of our myth and some of our
religion is inconsistent with it it's
time to change the myth and the religion
we simply have to keep an open mind
all of us philosophers scientists
religious people no one in fact knows
you